so tell the story in the book of a woman
called lenoir skanazi who you guys
should totally have on you'd absolutely
love her hero so lenore leonardo grew up
in a suburb of chicago in the 1960s
and
kind of normal suburb and from when she
was five years old she would leave home
on her own to go to school and she'd
walk on her own to the school which was
15 minutes away she'd generally bump
into the other kids that all walked
together when they got to the school
gate there was a ten-year-old boy whose
job was to help the five-year-olds
across the street right
she going to school she'd stayed there
till three o'clock or whatever the time
was she'd leave on her own she'd play
games with the other kids in the
neighborhood and she'd find her way home
for like 6 p.m right
by the time lenore had kids of her own
in the 90s she was living in queens in
new york
that had completely ended right she was
expected to walk her child to school and
be waiting at the school gate when he
came out by 2003 only 10 of american
children ever played outside right
without an adult ever and i think of the
10 who did the average amount of time
they did was like 12 minutes so
basically childhood suddenly moved even
before kovid to be something that
happened basically in imprisonment right
children are hidden behind closed doors
the only place they ever get to explore
anything is on fortnight and world of
warcraft so we can hardly be surprised
they become absolutely obsessed with
them right and it's not a coincidence i
think that this complete transformation
of childhood which we were just on the
cusp of like i played outside did you
guys play outside yeah of course all the
time exactly completely we we're we're
basically the last people in the western
world who as kids got to play outside
and i don't think it's a coincidence
that this huge transformation of
childhood
coincided with an enormous increase in
children's attention problems because if
you look at this
unprecedented change that's happened
there's never been a generation of human
children ever who were kept inside their
homes when we were kids or when our
parents were kids if someone kept their
child locked away all day i mean that
would have been regarded as child abuse
right
this transformation contains all sorts
of smaller changes that have
people's attention think about a really
simple one
exercise
the evidence that exercise is good for
your brain is
overwhelming it massively improves your
attention if you're struggling to focus
go for a run right we have prevented our
children from exercising only 73 percent
of elementary schools in the united
states have any form of recess right if
you wanted to up children's ability
to focus you would be so crazy
73 have any so
that's 27 have no recess so three out of
four do have recess yeah but even those
it's very small right so and a quarter
have no recess at all right so you can
see i would ditch so but the reason why
lenore is such a hero is because look i
can tell that to you and you're a parent
and i'm sure you think yeah that's true
but also you're like if i'm the only
person who lets my kid go out to play
the kid gets scared like a crazy person
so lenore built a big part of the
solution so that
obviously most of my book style and
focus is about how we solve these
problems and lenora i think pioneered a
key part for kids
so what she does is she goes to whole
schools and whole neighbourhood she runs
something called let grow and her
parents listen and go to let grow.org
she goes to whole schools and
neighborhoods and persuades them to let
their kids go out to let them she
believes that for children to be able to
become functioning adults they have to
be able to experience increasing levels
of independence in their lives right you
have to face challenges you become
resilient exactly what you're saying you
have to have a little bit of suffering
you have to get lost literally just
saying this yesterday at least
you have to climb the tree and you know
maybe you're gonna maybe you're gonna
hurt yourself what we've done is we've
we've taken that away so what lenore
does they go and they persuade whole
communities to start to restore
childhood and one of the most moving
experiences i had for the book was i
spent a lot of time with the let grow
projects i went to one in long island
and there was a boy there a 14 year old
boy and i'll give you a sense of this
he's a big strong 14 year old boy
who until this program had begun
his parents had never let him out of his
home on his own right they wouldn't even
let him go for a jog around the block
and they said it was i asked him why and
he said it's because they're afraid of
all these kidnappings he said to give
you a sense of this this is a town in
long island where the french bakery is
across the street from the olive oil
store
and he had a level of fear that would
have been appropriate if he'd lived in
colombia at the height of pablo
escobar's terror right it was insane um
so this program began
him and his friends start to go outside
without their screens
they start to play with each other which
they'd never done before and after a few
months what these boys did they went
into the woods and they built a fort
and
and they went there even though their
cell phones didn't work there because
the pleasures of building something of
exploring the real world and i remember
when that boy left
lenoir said to me lenore was with me
that day she said think about all of
human history
right young men had to go out they had
to hunt they had to seek they had to
build things
and in the space of one generation we
took all that away and those boys given
just a little bit of freedom what did
they do they went and they built a fort
right this is so important for attention
to be able to explore and build if you
just blunt a child
and it was so sad because i was thinking
about all the kids i know
who don't ever get that does does that
all ring treat you guys of course i mean
i lived in germany if in iran my dad
wouldn't let me play outside because he
was so worried about
you know what they were doing the
climate wasn't healthy for kids to play
outside although my dad would take us
out on friday to park his shahan shahi
it was the shah's name they changed the
name since there
and we would play outside we would he
would always want her to take us outside
except not without him once we went to
germany at a refugee camp
i was out in the streets till 10 o'clock
at night my mom had no clue where i was
at and let me tell you
my uh maturity from being a boy who was
timid and couldn't be around people to
being a man happened in germany at a
refugee camp from 10 years old to 12
years old if it wasn't for those two
years at germany playing with
catherine and katarina staff and jan and
all those guys johan from poland and you
know learning about yugoslavia a friend
of ours was from anna maria was her name
and they live in canada we found each
other on facebook it just wouldn't be
the same i totally agree with you on the
dependent side so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]